Identification. This is session for.
With FAITH BANDLER recorded with Carolyn Craig in Sydney on Friday the seventh of June one thousand nine hundred
seventy. This is site A and the interview will begin in approximately ten seconds time and of identification of. Faith.
You know that the experience of the depression meant a great deal to you and.
I believe would you like to talk about what that meant to you and your family while. Your side should talk about this.
My father died you know twenty four when we was still living in and we moved away from there. Very soon after.
I think it was sometime at nineteen twenty six. I was already at school probably first year out of you to go. And.
I was too young to know to a stranger it's only now as I look back I think about it you know I think about the clothes
my mother herself used to wear
and they were of the very best quality good clothes like those test socks white blouse it was.
Kids nothing like had to be the soft. Sought to skid boots and things began to change like in one hundred twenty seven.
We were already living in. And I recall my class being asked to. Come the next day all spruced up in him best clothes.
We didn't wear uniforms in primary school. And so I.
My mother spruced me have and
when I got to scold a whole class was taken from the school to the local railway station
and all classes were taken with a teacher.
I think it was in the month of February but I wouldn't be sure but I never it was the month.
That the Federal Parliament House in Cannes promoters opened.
Because the purpose of that trip to the Raju station was to welcome the Queen Mother who they in was the Duchess of
York and her husband who became king was the Duke of York
and they'd come out to open the he new Parliament House in Canberra and those days of course I'd come
and get on a train and go to all the at back places including Mumbai. And we were taken here. And I recall that.
They were in an all white tray the train was white. But it was a steam train if you please.
And she
and her husband where a school should out with only officials to sit on the platform there was a platform that sort of
face. The public.
There was a platform where the train came in and you walked through passage way than the was not a very long for.
Used usually for the trucks. Taxis or whatever. And this woman and her husband and I set like images on this platform.
And we had to stand there in the heat. And sing God Save the gracious. Whoever it was King then.
And the long speeches by people who didn't mean anything to me including the mayor and over.
And so we were then taken back to school and told we could. Now that was nine hundred twenty seven. I think.
And it was not until twenty twenty eight twenty and that I saw changes developing in our household and first of all.
My mother was battling obviously to keep things together.
The boys were all out working and I came home and would give my mother extra money they'd never put it you know him.
They just leave it on the kitchen table. And. We were still eating good food in twenty eight twenty nine.
We were that dependent on what we had grown. And who was still there into the butcher shop and the grocer's shop.
Whenever the need was there. In nineteen thirty. And and you know as well up in primary school. Very much.
And I was aware that it was.
Difficult for my mother to keep for me I was aware that she was becoming far more dependent on what we.
We were no longer buying any of those luxuries like apples or oranges which were not grown up. And.
Like I can recall my mother saying. You do the shopping get a pound pounder steak for brazing or whatever.
And the butcher would always throw a little extra.
Like a Man to add a couple of sausages or something like that and I would go home
and my mother would say oh yes he is a time man and you see.
And it seemed to me that previously about you would never do that and they you know came the day.
when I had to do what was called a Q.C. And asked what was known as Class and the sound of my school shoes coming off.
And I can remember my mother being very anxious that I should do that excess.
And she had a great big meal which we called a power. And she thread that I have. And she stitched all of that back on.
So I could get. Her own.
Boots by then she was in shoes I think women were in choosing and polishing her shoes that much more.
And instead of all her old shoes had flown out and she went in boats and shoes which were the chiefest of all shoes
and she'd wear those around the house and in the garden.
And that was the real come down if you put your feet in same shoes in my mother's. It's been. Different today.
You know if you get around this. Night Reeboks and all that you know depression no such thing. Of course was no no no.
If you're same shoes. You're at the very bottom of the ladder. And I go into town.
With my mother and there'd be that many more people wearing same shoes.
And I'm like today as my mother and her peers or is it you're not dressed if you haven't got decent shoes.
To see so many women in particular coming in from the outback like you know a few miles out of town
and coming in on Saturday or Friday which if it was either one or the other it would be soon choose
and I can say also Mrs Towne she was wearing the same shoes and her mother said the poor do you.
Goodness me it's a terrible life for the people. And.
These are all little signs that things were things getting less getting worse.
Yes And then we were no longer in prayed and prayed in fact became a luxury.
You know older sisters and my mother would make that much more damper or scar
or Johnny cakes you know things like that as supplements and. There were other changes and then finally.
Just stayed another two years at school.
But it became impossible and people of my age and I were all white people who we always thought had much more money
and income than we had but I hadn't actually
and I began leaving school because I couldn't afford to stay there anymore. Oh.
And kids were leaving at thirty and forty. And I thought you know if they can play second I'm sick of this.
So I think I was just about sixteen fifteen. But there I think I was coming up sixteen and I thought.
Well I did but that also opened the before that. Like I saw people standing outside of the police station.
And first of all a queue would be say ten or twelve
and that queue grew over the weeks as it were in the nineteen thirty.
And a bit after that but with my own ass I saw that cube growing in who were independent people. Men who had true.
And although there was a thing as farmers relief.
You'd see families standing in the queue and it was getting longer and longer
and our boys looked on these people as people who not only had more money than we. But people who were more secure.
And here they were waiting for an adult ticket.
A ticket that would give some license to go to certain grocery shops in the town
and buy something like I've forgotten but I'm out of the you know.
Two pounds worth of groceries which was a lot of money in an awful lot.
And so then I had a brother who got in that queue because the train was finished the season was finished
and he got in the queue and he'd come home. And he this was a brother who came home and lived with us.
He didn't live in the house. That we were living in. He actually lived in that was a churning.
But he'd come home with a free.
I think that was once a month for not coming with a few slabs of cheese tin fish herrings into matters sauce
and packets a chair lease or cancer cheap food but a lot of what and lots of flour and sugar. That I couldn't buy.
Because bacon was not a luxury bank and was cheap
and you could go to one of the local store then buy a pound of part of a sixpence.
Because if they couldn't get they had to. Now would he have money and then I saw all of this occurring before.
And my brother wearing say.
And he used to use an excuse and pretend it wasn't because he didn't have enough money to buy kid
but same shoes you could walk much faster in them. And the clothes would wear out. And they weren't replace him.
You know it was always a great thing to replace clothes before they were worn out and my mother
and my uncle who was a father figure. Then because my father and I would take us to the local the very best local shop.
It was cool man by the name of proud Ford.
And like I knew him and he knew them and I would always greet each other and I pulled a high chair for him
and he'd say we brought the girls in to select material.
And we would select usually a feature which was beautiful daughter of different colors
and that wasn't happening any more.
And when the dresses were at they wore out
and there was a local Draper shop which was not it wasn't considered the place to go to the issue really.
Because all the stuff was cheap and wasn't good.
And my mother would never go to them but now she began to come and the attendance would come out into the street
and big people to go in and we have this on special LATE say you know to me six months.
Or it's only a shilling a day and my mother began going there and that was a big leap there.
No longer too proud for it's. I think in one of your books you talk about your mother.
Hosting a lot of the men who were out of work in a depression they'd come to your place to sit around and talk
and she would. She would give them hospitality. Yes well when of course. When I was still at school.
The depression of course had taken hold in the city.
There was no doubt about that and actually I remember one family coming all the way from Melbourne.
Out of the city of Melbourne to live in a house that wasn't very far from our place whose relative to relatives didn't
have need of it and they lived there rent free and they sold all the Christmases and come at once.
No longer having a landlord they could go outside and pick fresh fruit.
And so my mother went Oh my brothers really had left working on different.
Except maybe who came and went and he being there was a great help because he got all this dull food.
And men began to arrive from. Southern cities Melbourne and Sydney in particular. They've just come and ask.
Could they cut a little mood. For some braid.
There were some were from banks because the banks had closed
and some were students mainly students who would come up as far. And some.
They get a fishing rod and get a fish and roasted on the bank they do things like this but when they come to matter.
She don't give them enough. First of all that comes from board chop some wood.
And she'd never trust them to do any gardening because she said they didn't have a clue
and they should give them a knife and a spoon and direct them to the pan Apple patch.
If the primary force were right and I would have to tell them how to cut the top of the pot apple
and then scoop it up with a spoon and make a meal of it and I wouldn't go back to the house
and my mother would watch when they'd go she said to make sure that if the spoon.
It's impossible for me to describe the misery in seeing proud people.
Terrible thing really the depression and these men would come and they tell others the same
and the local showground would be a place where they would camp.
I recall on one morning very early at half past six the.
Call police sergeant who was in charge of the local cop shop arrived on his who're.
And got his Coulter out and my mother went out to greet him
and he said Mrs nursing we have just found a party at the showground it's very dark
and I have wondered if you knew anyone who would come and identify it because it might be an island person.
And we found someone a man who wouldn't know identified it but it happened a white person had gone down.
And people were just dying. And although I thought I had terrible all of this really.
And my sister incidentally cat got a job at a local farm she was older than me brighter than me.
Harley intelligent extremely sensitive and very loving and very responsible.
And she took a job with a local a local farmer who. Had chooks.
And I traced chokes and fill their cart up and take them from the hood and over
and beautiful fresh books their name was Affleck and they came from South Africa.
And the woman the wife was Australian but he'd come from South Africa.
And so she came to our house one day and asked if anyone needed. And my sister. Oh yes I'll come for you.
So she said well if you must be there by half past four in the morning.
Well it was no trouble to us because we went to bed with the chicks and half the time.
So careful to leave her four o'clock and. Climb over the it's green. Her long legs go like lightning.
And kill the chokes and then stand at the bench with Mrs Affleck and dress. No gloves no nothing. And dress nicely.
And then you can have her six Affleck.
The Affleck's would if they had little wear little cock with all the grease trucks and they'd do the rounds of town.
And you could choke a dress check for two and sixpence.
Well the good thing about calf working there was the cheaper in the giblets. And. What I proposed soup.
With lots of vegetable it was marvelous and then she'd make a kind of johnny cake
and she put the giblets in the johnny cake. And followed it over and that would be a meal.
But if you are wonderful and you know a lot of things like that you put on.
So in some ways compared to people in town the people in the city. Really lived a relatively.
Except you know when I see my mother straining to textbooks. And. We could no longer afford to buy.
Because that person that I used to do my homework. And we started to use candles because they were cheap.
And I do my homework by candlelight. Little these things that made it extremely hard.
We have for all those for breakfast because. Of course you could buy a pound of products for a bad happens.
And at the time you realize the value very good for us. Anyhow.
I can recall people coming cousins of our house who lived in
and they were very flash they were the children of a stepsister of my mother.
And they came to them came and my mother said you can stay with us.
And I thought I should have gotten a first soon as we should be worrying about them
but the truth in fact that in Brisbane I had absolutely nothing just nothing
and it was something for them to hit such a table that. Their character food.
And look at it because they had a nice house in the city
but if I went back to that house they wouldn't have said if so at least I had food with us and.
Oh yes and then one night. And this must never. Night in thirty seven.
And you see we have told through all this to stay. You know to stay healthy.
Apart from battling to keep the clothes on and back. Was it difficult feel mother I mean I had. Didn't.
My mother had remarkable inner recently and.
She just took it as it came and most women who did not continue to make ends meet.
There were major terrific stuff those. And there was nothing from the government to give them.
Like today there was a lot of care. A lot of battering and that saved their lives in the country after things like.
The Irish families on their way to mass would bring us homemade biscuits.
Of homemade tomato sauce and are very often every Sunday morning as a matter of fact.
And we leave at the slip arrive home little boxes of whatever fruit and eggs.
What if it was going yams sweet potatoes or something like that
and that time I had asked him over for quite a few days during the week. There was no OK sure.
And it was very little cash. And I was given. Was always even six months on a Monday because that was banking.
The time came and my mother said look. You use that sixpence to buy two three pence each beautiful.
And the parliament would come here to the school nice little card with a little tiny little chimney smoking.
And I found that often the only big three or four of us buying it because it would come out and very often.
In the winter. You know kids would come out bleeding feet to school. Frostbitten. And there was no way.
They didn't have open fires. But most of them had. They'd have to stay in the kitchen. Most people cooked by a few.
And a quarter an extent they put us but we not only had a sister. We had fires. It kept us.
In the blankets became a thing in. And lank so expensive to buy. Blankets.
I would just imagine that was never that never seem to be reduced and it was really cold in the winter. And.
The blankets began to wear his.
And my mother would say calf would you put another patch on that blanket use that are all cutting and I've cut out.
And women women making petticoats getting air and like if you had.
A dress that was worn in the seat would you cut the top part.
And cut it into patches for a patch quilt and do you turn things inside out. You had to use a lot of invention.
I have so little. And John my oldest brother was a great need. And you can buy skins of all cheaply.
You couldn't buy things like blankets and I can remember using big knitting rug for a baby and put next.
But that was another thing that I hope people being evicted. And.
But we didn't care you know I like my mother cared but we were too young to care what was happening to other people.
Miracle to keep us afloat. It was something very significant that I could finish. It's left me that I think I've got.
It. Now what happened was that my mother had money in the bank. Which was then called a savings bank.
And that was a government owned bank that later became the Commonwealth Bank. And if you want me. It was very hard.
You were only allowed to take so much out. And this is what I couldn't bloody well understand it was our money.
And why should my mama go and stand in a queue for her own money and I only take so much.
I thought it was almost like the situation for Aboriginal people in Queensland you know if they wanted the money they
earned which is banked in the Commonwealth Bank they took a police car.
The cops and say I want to buy a new bike or a new coat
or something like that before they could use their own money to the bank put these restrictions on everybody. Oh yes.
No one no one and you tended to door closed. Most of the time or some of the time.
It's all a bit vague to me but that was what distressed me was that my mother would take me into the bank.
And she would only be allowed like to drove five pounds or something
and she had quite a lot of money in the bank because by this time my uncle had died
and he left her a bag of gold song for us. And they were in the bank.
So fortunate and she wanted to take them out because the local.
Greek restaurant which is still a to this day much mention the list by name. They would that I would give.
To Paris for goes over. And there's an awful lot of money.
And we were all angry about this and now my file has some of his cousins and friends.
It doesn't matter if it stops now there were people who paid money and they were careful
and over into the Commonwealth Bank and there were about ten or twelve of them one day. They were all going for.